foreign
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists we're here with our
good friend TK Coleman what it is
Alabama's in the studio hi everybody we
got the rest of our team here as well
coming up today on this free public
minimal episode we're talking to a
listener about how to stop saying yes we
also have an outstanding lightning round
listener tip an added value segment for
you you can check out the full two hour
maximal edition of episode 361 where we
answer four times the questions and we
dive deep into several simple living
segments Ryan and I also get into a
serious argument
all you need to know is that I won
all right anyway you can check that out
patreon.com the minimalist it's over two
hours long your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because say it with
me y'all
advertisements suck by the way Josh when
I win you win also ah so we both won I
feel like a winner yeah me too man
I'm Alabama where do you want to start
today let's start with a question from
Mary in Springfield Virginia
my name is Mary and I'm from Springfield
Virginia I'm a teacher my job brings me
joy and gives me purpose but for the
first time in over a decade of teaching
I've decided to work part-time I did
this in order to create space to better
support and be more present with my
daughters how does someone who is a
people-pleasing hard-working
quote-unquote good girl manage the guilt
I feel when saying no to requests to do
all the things I did when I was
full-time or how do I manage the
disappointment I feel when asked to do
things beyond my hours without
compensation I realize that this is
something that a lot of women and
especially teachers wrestle with I want
to learn how to address these feelings
so that I can continue to say no and
hopefully teach my daughters how to do
the same so how do you say no and then
let it go TK this is a difficult one
because it is much harder to say no when
we feel an incredible sense of joy and
purpose as Mary does so it's not like
she's dreading it it's easy to say no to
the things we dread right right if I'm
like hey TK do you want to help me go
pick up trash on the side of the road
today unless you have a really
compelling reason it's going to be
easier for you to say no because you
have something that is better to say yes
to
that's right implicit in every no is a
yes to something else even if that
something else is not something that is
highly adventurous to say no really
means I would rather be relaxing
enjoying my own my alone time taking a
nap being with a friend
planning out the rest of my week
whatever it may be it's something else
that you want to say yes to and
sometimes we avoid saying yes to
Alternatives and we give people these
no's that we don't want to give because
we're afraid we're going to be unloving
we're afraid we're going to be
inconsiderate and I actually think no is
sometimes the optimal expression of Love
sometimes the kindest most compassionate
thing you can do for another person is
to tell them no because when you tell
them no now you save them from the
resentment you will feel in the future
and you better be sure that bitterness
is going to be expressed in some other
kind of way it's better to risk looking
and sounding mean in the present than to
actually become mean in the future
because you didn't take care of yourself
and now you're engaging those very
people you want it to be nice to from a
place of resentment that's no good but
why does it feel so difficult in the
moment and it feels like the opposite of
compassion if I'm saying no to you right
now and you know how good I am at saying
no yeah but I wasn't always that way
yeah I filled my calendar with everyone
else's yeses because something was a
hell yes to someone I then took on their
yeses and unfortunately what that did is
it crowded out my own yes it's my
ability to say yes to the things that
were important to me and when I realized
Mary is that to be happy I had to stop
saying yes to the things that made me
miserable even though in the moment it's
really easy to say yes it's really easy
to commit my future self a week from now
a month from now especially a year from
now oh Ryan let's go ahead and put this
on our calendar for next February oh not
a problem because I don't have to worry
about it today but now I'm punishing My
Future Self so why is it so difficult to
say now in the moment yeah
no please allow me uh
no uh here's the thing is when you tell
someone no and you don't know how they
uh interpreted that no
for me it would be easy to feel guilty
because I might assume the worst like oh
this person doesn't like me anymore
thinks that I don't like them or they're
not a priority or I don't care about
them we start uh telling ourselves these
stories catastrophizing yeah that we're
totally making up am I repeating
yourself
what does catastrophizing mean Josh give
us the word of the day I mean it just
doesn't mean making something up yeah it
means that we turn everything into a
catastrophe what's the worst case
scenario right oh yes right and it's and
it may not even be true but that's the
story We Tell ourselves
um uh and God forbid we expect the best
like oh you know what they understood
yeah they love me so much like I don't
have to explain myself right yeah um so
I know that sometimes uh in the past
when I would say no that's probably why
I was feeling guilty so when you tell
someone no
and you let them know why you said no
and that they understand that I think
that is maybe how Mary can uh avoid some
of this guilt because then she doesn't
have to make up stories in her head I
got a really good friend who was like
hey man you know when I first met him
and we're hitting it off and he's like
hey uh really would love you to like to
show up
um at this meeting uh that I host and
you know it's a bunch of entrepreneurs
you know he pitches me and I'm like hey
man I love you I was like but I I can't
commit like if I commit to this then I'm
gonna be fully invested and I have to
say no to this so I can say yes to like
keeping that two or three hours on
Friday mornings uh available for me and
um he has brought that up so much he's
like you have no idea how much I
respected you for saying that and like
letting me know
um so yeah Mary if you're if you're
letting someone know what you're saying
yes to then
um then yeah you can probably like go
with some of that guilt I would I would
presume yeah you know sometimes the
people who demand or request a lot of us
almost like guiltlessly to the point
where we resent them for putting us in
these positions where we have to say no
sometimes those people are really good
for us because they challenge us to
think more specifically and
intentionally about the lives that we
want to live and the things that we want
to do and sometimes we may not even
think about what version of helping
someone we would be happy with and then
when they come to us and say hey do this
to make me happy we just say yes to what
they request out of guilt but when you
have a hard time saying no to people and
you feel guilty it's usually because you
care about them if this is someone that
you absolutely hate it you just say no
with no problem but it's because you
actually do like this person and you do
want to help them and that's a good
thing but when you're in that position I
would take a moment to think about what
a fun and feasible way of helping them
looks like for you and you don't have to
say yes or no in the moment you can say
hey give me a minute to think about that
I don't know let me have a minute and
then you can take a minute and come back
and say hey I can't do it that way but I
can do it this way I can't do it on that
day but I can do it on this day I can't
do it for that amount of time but I can
do it for this amount of time so you
don't always have to say no sometimes
you can say yes to their request in a
way that's best for you yeah it's it's
interesting finding ways to say yes yeah
that are renegotiating the terms of the
yeah someone reached out on patreon
recently and and they were like hey I
realized that listening to the
minimalist podcast the ideal speed is
1.3 times the normal speed and for me I
like listening at like 1.8 so it's the
ideal for that person is 1.3 I like
listening 1.8 and she asked hey is it
possible on the patreon app to listen at
1.3 and my initial response was well no
you can I have to listen to 1.25 or 1.5
I hear the options that are available
right but I got to thinking well yes
there is a way I can say yes to this
because most people listen to with a
private podcast the audio version of the
private podcast via their favorite
podcast app like apple podcast or Feedly
or a cast or whatever you use and when I
was talking to them I was like well yeah
just listen to in your favorite app
here's here are the instructions so it
wasn't a yes we'll get patreon because
what they changed their infrastructure
it was no most people actually listen
this way and I can say yes but the term
terms are a little bit different yeah
get creative with that yes sometimes we
treat people as if they're being weak if
they struggle with saying no we we treat
them as if they're being a a pushover if
they really want to say yes but your
desire to say yes just means that these
are people that you feel some genuine
compassion for it you love serving them
and if you can be creative with that yes
you can do it in a way that really feels
right for you and it will feel right
only if it doesn't make you miserable
and then we're made miserable Often by
our expectations we're going to talk
later in the private podcast episode
about every relationship bringing us
misery and how our expectations bring us
misery and so Mary I want to send you a
copy of our book it's called Everything
That Remains it's Ryan's in my second
book we wrote it a decade ago and it was
really the story of two guys who started
saying no to the expectations of the
corporate world started saying no in
ways we hadn't before it was really
shocking to people at first because when
you say yes yes yes yes yes yes and all
of a sudden someone Hears A no it's
breaking the pattern it's breaking that
pattern of yes and that's how we have to
do it it's like if I haven't gone to the
gym in a long time and then I start
going to the gym I'm probably going to
be sore the next day so the first few
knows are going to make you a little bit
sore because you're so used to saying
yes but that soreness that saying no
or stopping you're not even saying no
really you're stop saying yes to
everything that's what you got to do you
got to stop saying yes to everything
that's making you miserable because
otherwise you're just going to continue
to be miserable so if you like our
podcast I think you'll enjoy the
audiobook version of everything that
remains or if you want the book book or
the ebook version we'll send those to
you any last words from Mary can you
speak really quickly to the compensation
question she asked she's doing some work
for free and it's and she doesn't want
to do it but she feels bad about the
fact that she would rather have the
compensation or be off work can you
speak to that yeah I mean there's
nothing wrong with being compensated
right wanting to be compensated for your
work uh Ryan and I and TK we all get
compensated for the work we do but we
don't do the work for the compensation
the way that I like to think about it is
money is a passenger in the car but I
never let it behind the wheel yeah it'd
be disingenuous to say it that plays no
role whatsoever because we live in a
society that requires the exchange of of
money and so there's nothing wrong with
wanting to be compensated for what you
do the problem and we're going to talk
later about some of the problems of
capitalism because a lot this question
comes up a lot for the minimalists and I
want to make some distinctions there but
the problem here is not the desire to be
compensated it's the fact that you feel
you might feel used if you aren't
compensated it feels unfair to you right
yeah and by the way the monetarily
monetary compensation is not merely the
only way to be compensated for something
that's a good distinction well sometimes
too I mean you got to put a barrier up
like if you have a skill or a service or
whatever it is that is really desired
and people are constantly asking you to
provide that for free
um sometimes you got to put up a little
bit of a barrier to kind of um filter
out some of those asks yeah yeah you got
to think about the the other people in
your life as well so you may not care
about the money or compensation very
much but the time that you're giving up
might be something that the children you
want to spend time with they can be
affected by that so either demand that
compensation or demand that time because
both your money and your time is
something that you can use to serve your
family Ryan what time is it oh Josh you
know what time it is it's time for the
lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions your comments your compliments
your compusaults you can text all those
things to
937-202-4654 yes indeed now during the
lightning round this is where we do our
best to answer questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we put a minute on the clock
for each of us so we can ramble on a
little bit by the way we copy and share
our pithy quotes on social media you can
find all of our minimal maxims in the
show notes and over at minimalmaxims.com
thanks to our good friend social Jess
looks like Lehigh has a question for us
I struggle with managing anger towards
what I personally receive as wrongdoing
or Injustice any ideas on how to deal
with this let's put 60 seconds on the
clock for Ryan Nicodemus I was just
reading your juice is great uh yes my my
pit the answer is this radical inclusion
requires complete acceptance so I this
came to me uh because of LA traffic
honestly like I have really been going
out of my way to just accept the fact
that Los Angeles is the way it is
there's you know 12 million people in LA
county and uh you're gonna have people
who don't know how to drive so the other
day
um yesterday we pull up to get on the
405. um there's this Porsche behind me
kind of riding my butt on the exit and
then the lane splits to go to the two
red lights and it's you know alternating
green lights one car per person right um
so I pull up to the red light and this
guy just like goes around me and runs
the red light and I am instantly like
this entitled jerk blah blah but then
I'm like no man write a conclusion baby
like how what's the compassionate
approach what's the charitable approach
to this situation and I was like oh this
this dude doesn't feel like he has
enough and how how how he must feel to
just constantly take all the time yeah
all right I got the Buzzard so I'm done
let's throw another 60 seconds on the
clock for TK Coleman
feelings are not there to be conquered
they are there to be engaged with
imagination
I like that you feel bothered by
Injustice
if you're on a bus and you see some
Teenage kid push an old lady aside just
so he can get the last bus seat I like
that that bothers you we need somebody
in this world to be bothered by the
attacks and the assaults that go against
human dignity we need somebody in this
world who can observe tragedy and say
you know what I don't like that and I
don't like pretending like I'm okay with
that we could all go get lobotomies
right now and not have any fillings
negative or positive and just be in some
state of passive peace but we need
people in this world who get angry and
that anger is not there to be exercised
that anger is there to be engaged with
creativity how can I Channel those
feelings of anger along constructive
lines so that I can step up and do
something about the things that need to
be done that's what we need I don't
think I could handle another lobotomy
Professor Sean give me 60 seconds here
Ryan I love what you were saying earlier
about the Porsche that cut you off
because you can get mad about that you
can see that Injustice and you can get
really frustrated by it now you're
punishing yourself for his bad behavior
yeah and as soon as we realize that we
can laugh at the absurdity of it maybe
he did something that was creating some
sort of micro Injustice but that
Injustice is does not give me an excuse
to make myself miserable I can let it go
and that's so important with respect to
my pithy answer which is this
Mo expectations Mo emotions
problems right
though I
feel all of these different emotions
that I don't necessarily want to feel
I'm open myself up for anger for sadness
for depression for despair for Guilt for
rage
if I have all of these different
expectations but if I declutter those
expectations I run out of time you even
got the clock in front of you oh you can
finish that though
here's what I'll say if I if I have more
and more and more expectations I'm going
to make room for the emotions I don't if
I declutter those expectations when I
actually make room for is contentment
peace I'm uncovering the pre-existing
peace that is already there but I'll ask
you guys a question please please do
have either of you ever been in a
situation especially you Josh where your
anger LED you to do something about it
that was positive
no anger led to do something I know you
got one from burning man but I don't
know if you want to tell it yeah we
already did that we're out of time no
man like when he saw somebody doing
something inappropriate he can tell us
in 30 seconds no I already told that
story oh you didn't tell that story yeah
he did he told it on the podcast
about the dude doing the thing and he
was like if you do that punch you in the
face with the flag I thought you were
telling me that offline no no oh I don't
think of pictures that he shouldn't have
been taking oh you really don't remember
this no I'm gonna punch you in the face
or something oh no this was okay this
was an edge Fest oh yeah and Dayton and
yes this dude was groping women
basically and I went up to and I was
like if I see you touch it because women
were crowd surfing yeah yeah and then I
went up to him like if you touch another
woman I'm gonna punch you in the face
he was like what and I'm like you know
exactly what I'm talking about we don't
have to talk about it anymore if I see
you do it again I'm gonna put you in a
headlock and embarrass you in front of
all these people
and he stopped yeah I'm glad he got
bothered that was worth the extra 30
seconds brother thank you no I think I
think it's worth saying that our anger
can lead us down a direction toward
a product a productive outcome however
if we cling to that anger it's going to
escalate things in a way that
that actually prevent us from going the
direction which we want to go so anger
is data that will often point us in the
direction of quote unquote Justice right
we got a lot more to talk about in fact
Ryan I want to disagree with you about
something coming up here a little bit on
our talk aboutable segment but first
from Alabama what do you got for us
here's a minimalist Insight from one of
our listeners hey y'all this is Emily
Stewart from Florence South Carolina and
I wanted to share a tip so I've been a
minimalist my entire life even as a kid
but I find myself thinking that I don't
have anything to get rid of because I'm
a minimalist so I came up with a game
with myself that kind of helps me to
keep cleaning things out I often shop at
Trader Joe's in Aldi's and I bring my
own bags but sometimes I forget and end
up having to grab the paper bags at
checkout so my new rule for myself is
every time I do this I have to fill up
the paper bags with things from my home
to give away or sell so although for
getting my own bags isn't good for the
environment it turned into a great way
to consistently clear out and help keep
it fun for me and fresh even though I am
have been a minimalist for so long all
right y'all before we get to our added
value segment real quick for right here
right now here's one thing going on in
the life of the minimalists well at
least one of the minimalists I uh have a
writing class called how to write better
and I've been doing these little short
videos on YouTube called bad writing I'm
going to be working on this new series
called good writing and we're doing an
audio version of that it's called the
how to write better podcast you can find
it wherever you listen to podcasts I'll
put a link in the show notes but the
little four or five minute lessons where
I show you an example of bad writing or
good writing or here's an example of how
to improve your grammar or use fewer
adverbs or adjectives we break down some
sentences we talk about books that are
really powerful when we talk about other
books and how they could be improved a
little five six minute chunks you can
digest you can walk away with something
today that will improve your riding it's
100 advertisement free it's called the
how to write better podcast and the
first three episodes are available right
now you can find them wherever you
listen to podcasts or head on over to
how to
writebetter.org for added value this
week guys oh Ryan they all went downhill
after Okay computer
[Laughter]
I was listening to this uh over dinner
uh this week and I was playing it and
Bex she's like man this she looks at the
name of the band and it's called the
smile and so the added value this week
is this band called the smile and Bex
was like
that this sounds so much like Radiohead
I'm like well it kind of is Radiohead
yeah so Tom York and Johnny Greenwood
who are the two main members of
Radiohead or two of the main members of
Radiohead they partnered with this Jazz
drummer named Tom Skinner and they
created this band during the pandemic
called the smile and so it is Radiohead
esque which radiohead's one of my
favorite bands of all time and this
music it's sort of
ethereal it's great sort of lying around
the house with nothing to do music like
while we're just hanging out we're
eating dinner we're being calm so the
song you're hearing in the background
right now if you're listening to the
audio version of the podcast is a song
called waving a white flag from the
smiles one and only album it's an album
called a light for attracting attention
or if you're watching the YouTube
version on the public podcast you'll see
a link you can click on if you want to
hear the song as well what made you pick
that particular song the way that it
started was just so
it felt like it was right for our
podcast yeah and it was a great way to
end this episode because we're talking
about feelings we're talking about
saying no but if we can say no with a
smile how much more powerful is that
than no no no no
I could say no I don't think that's for
me I want to say it with a smile so
enjoy waving a white flag by the way TK
we got a bunch more surprise questions
on the private podcast this week like
what natural remedies can I use to calm
my anxiety
how do you know the difference between
being intentional and seeking pleasure
how do I improve the communication in my
relationship to prevent arguments plus a
million more questions for the
minimalists and if they want to hear all
that malabama tell them what to do check
out the minimalist private podcast visit
patreon.com the minimalists or click the
link in the description to subscribe and
get your personal links so that our
weekly maximal episodes play in your
favorite podcast app you'll also gain
immediate access to all of our archives
recordings of Live Events weekly home
tours and our private community of
thousands of open-minded minimizers like
you in fact here's a thoughtful
testimonial from one of our lovely
patreon podcast supporters Jamie says I
have been a private podcast subscriber
for a little over a month now and I
can't begin to tell you how much you
guys have enriched my life I was in a
bad place of anxiety and feeling lost
with no way out
I started listening to your public
podcast and kept wanting to hear more so
I finally decided to join you on patreon
I'm so grateful I did I've begun to
declutter my personal items and my
mental clutter as well just one month
Jamie we have to go back back charge you
now for all the archives
for Jamie and welcome aboard to all of
our new patrons working uh people
comment on this episode Mal they can
comment on youtube.com the minimalists
and if you have a question or listener
tip for our podcast give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast
theminimalist.com follow the minimalists
on tiktok Instagram Facebook and Twitter
at the minimalist and to get our podcast
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list at the minimalist.com thank
you Alabama that is our show for today
folks on behalf of Ryan Nicodemus TK
Coleman Alabama podcast Sean Jordan no
more Professor Sean social justice Danny
unknown post-production Peter Emma The
Immigrant and the rest of our team I'm
Joshua Fields Milburn if you leave here
today with just one message let it be
this
love people and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time peace
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed or I bet that you'll
be fine without it thank you